high school teammates and great friends
jack flaherty and lucas giolito battling
one another
on the mound as we get started tonight
how about this note the last time
giolito faced
a national league opponent he no hit the
pittsburgh pirates on august 25th
2020. so let's see what he has up his
sleeve tonight he was
very good his last time out in minnesota
with joe west behind the plate
in his 5 376th game
a new major league record the san diego
chicken handing flowers to joe west then
a wonderful embrace
fun with poultry tonight does that
change-up is hit to right for
adam eaton for round number one now
dylan
carlson another switch batter he's
playing center field tonight
on two and two that's strike three the
mystery
changeup carlson couldn't pull the
trigger
well i love the fact that carlson
literally was leaving the plate before
joe west made the call
he realizes he's outguessed a 1-0 pitch
to the cardinal first baseman
is lined into left that's a base hit
vaughan to try to cut it off and the
throw into second base
it's in time and they got him andrew
vaughn with a big defensive play
goldschmidt with two outs trying to get
in scoring position
and he is out seven to four
clarity goes to the mount for his tenth
start he's eight no his team is nine and
oh in his nine starts
era of two and a half you see the
strikeouts 55 and 53 in the third
most amazing stat is he'll use a lot of
four seam fastballs and
surprisingly a lot of right hand hitters
will take them for strike three
38 of his strikeouts to right hand
hitters have come
taking either a slider or a fastball and
that's what he'll lean on
one and two from jack flaherty
this to shortstop and sosa bobbles it
tim is safe at first there's a perfect
example of a young shortstop
letting the ball play him you see how he
waits back on this he actually puts on
the brakes
to wait back and then gets a hop he's
not expecting the ball trickles out of
the glove
johan moncada to right field and
playable for
out number one for the cardinals
tommy edmond throws it in as tim gets to
third
first and third with one out and here's
jose abreu
eaton goes tapped toward third it's fair
picked up by flared he throws to first
in time to get abreu
anderson will score and the white sox
have the lead
a bare-handed pickup by flaherty
thought he might let it roll but i think
it would have stayed fair jose will take
the rbi mercedes will bat eaton
to second mercedes drives it to right
tommy edmond dropped the ball
edmond drops the ball and the socks get
run number two
so look the cardinals are short on
outfielders
edmond playing right field not his usual
position
cannot put away the final out of the
inning you got to be
really mentally tough to get through
this inning at this point just let it
all go
you know your teammates aren't trying to
mess you over
and mess up routine plays
starting second baseman last night
edmond starting in right field
had that hit right off the heel of his
mitt
and just flat out missed it the
right-handed batter
swings and he gets one in the air center
field
carlson backing up he's at the track
near the wall and makes the catch
he kept drifting with evelyn add room
and retires vaughn and the white sox
nick madrigal the batter and he's trying
to move the runners along
and we're going to center field this is
down a base hit
it kicks off at carlson zach's coming
home the throw is not nearly in time
and the sox are using some wonky defense
and a lot of contact to take an early
lead in game two
three and one to moncada out of the zone
ball four
and the sox have taken a four nothing
lead on a bases loaded walk well all
things considered this is about the
quietest four runs that you'll see
heirs walks hit batsman two out in the
second
this one gets away from molina here
comes madrigal it's five nothing
everyone moves up a base and the adier
molina
has not been supreme in this series so
far at blocking baseball
no there was a couple that got by two
hits in the inning
and an error base is loaded with one out
for
dylan carlson 3-1 and carlson
lifts a high fly ball down the right
field line
in the corner eaton goes up and makes
the catch
sosa tagging up as well as edmond and
the cardinals get on the board to make
it 5-1
that was very nearly foul very nearly a
home run but what it was
was a sacrifice flying an rbi for dylan
here's goldschmidt who's singled in the
first
big at bat in this game to third
moncada's got a chance to in the inning
and a braves got a stretch
did he keep the back the answer is yes
man jose
throws a life raft to another possible
run
but abreu just saved another error and
maybe
two more runs first and third with one
out the pitch bounces
and karim's away from collins
arenado will score carpenter to second
it's five to two on a wild pitch so
here's a brayer
runner at second one out jose drills his
fall
through the night sky and it is fair
a two-run rocket
for a 7-2 lead jose abreu
sitting on a first pitch slider and oh
my my my what a wonderful day he hit
every stitch on that baseball
seven to two white sox the white sox bat
in the sixth one on one out
and the pitch a brave base hit in the
center
he lines one past the drawn in infield
monkatta scores it's 8-2
and abreu has driven in half the white
sox runs
that's another change-up this guy's got
a big fastball but he keeps on throwing
jose changes
chokes up on the bat keeps his hands
close to his body and hits that ball
hard to
right center field that might drop and
it does that's gonna drop in front of
the right fielder
eaton matt carpenter scores and max
moore off his first
rbi and his first hit as a cardinal
they are loaded with nobody out and here
comes tony and that'll be it for crochet
so a double and two walks five run lead
but now the tying run is
on deck that means a safe spot for
hendricks there it is strike three
thomas sent away for out number one
[Applause]
struck him out two up two strikeouts
with the bases loaded
3-2 again fastball
strike three we'll see you tomorrow
hendricks comes in
and blitzes the cardinals striking all
three out